[Applaudissements]
je vais te faire toucher une partie de
mon corps ferme les yeux qui va trouver
ce que celle à nos scieries la luna
devant les téléspectateurs à capuche et
un ave qui les yeux fermés retire sa
main quand elle ne coûte quant à
comprend que celle ci se trouve sur le
sexe de l'animateur oui comme d'hab
répond ensuite capucines à naves à
mireille morini bosc qui lui demande si
l'animateur lui a mis la main sur son
sexe
voici une lettre ouverte à cyril hanouna
très cher cyril hanouna
oui tu ne coûte très cher et tu vas
comprendre pourquoi tu représentes pour
ma le degré zéro de la télévision ce qui
est encourageant te dirait un
instituteur
car tu ne peux que progresser à l'instar
de la télé réalité et ne te méprends pas
sur le mot star le télé spectateurs
assistent chaque jour à des programmes
sur automatique avec des acteurs
érotisée guidé par un arrivisme sociale
cette télévision renvoie aux lèvres et
aux reins et non au coeur et au cerveau
le téléspectateur femme athée est devenu
serein biche et qui s'est développé
jusqu'à l'absurde cette faculté de
pouvoir rester planté devant la télé
réalité cette infection ou l'esprit ne
rencontre plus que le vide alors que le
monde est plein c'est qu'on s'est
ingénié à faire vivre dans des décors de
ma photo animé d être plausible qui
participent à une mauvaise comédie avec
d'un côté un spectacle télé hygiénique
et de l'autre le téléspectateur qui en
retour devient responsable de cette
aberration d'un côté trop de feux de
l'amour interdisent la vue aux
naissances de l'autre l'aveuglément du
téléspectateur qui s'était éloigné de
lui même tu peux faire de toi
certains téléspectateurs ne peut plus
envisager un retour à d'autres formes de
programmes sont loin de à présent en
conscience vis existence peut-être
penser responsabilité inscrit dans un
scénario préalablement préalablement
écrit tu es censé nous représenter nous
tous au prétexte du dramaturge image est
basé sur le jeu des attractions et de
répulsion le téléspectateur mais surtout
l'homme a l'impression d'échapper
l'espace d'une émission à
l'irréversibilité destructrice du temps
pour ton téléspectateurs qui considère
qu'un programme intelligent ne lui doit
pas son existence il le rencontre que
lui même et son environnement restreint
pour cet homme aux questionnements
limité tu apportes des réponses qui
repousse plus loin encore son
questionnement on l'aura compris
avec ce énième dérapage la télévision
implique nécessairement pas l'attitude
de ses dirigeants envers la société
la pollution au brut chaque jour un peu
plus les messages que d'autres émissions
de qualité adresse aux téléspectateurs
je doute que tu connais cette célèbre
formule de malraux le 20e le 21e siècle
sera mystique ou ne sera pas grâce à toi
et à d'autres nous sommes en régression
en deçà de la raison
ton attitude donne un blanc seing à la
jeunesse qui ne manquera pas de timité
et ne te méprends pas sur le mot st
la ville ne reste la vie ne résistera
pas longtemps à 7 et 3 13 3 mois
des programmes qui ne pèsent pas de
graves d'intelligence accompagne la
formation des jeunes cerveaux et les
tracts sur tous les écrans dans les
régions les plus reculées de la france
nous commençons à avoir le recul
suffisant pour mesurer ce que ce déluge
démission débilitante produits sur les
jeunes cerveaux laisse trop tard pour la
génération actuelle
probablement alors si c'est ça être
intelligent cyril je ne vois pas
l'intérêt
l'homme s'agit aujourd'hui mais
pourra-t-il encore demain tu m'en fera
dix pages mais je doute que tu as not
dépasse à nouveau le zéro de conduite
prenons un autre exemple
pire si je puis dire parce que dans le
domaine de latéralité ya toujours pire
avec tv serbie et son programme par ovi
c'est un programme où les
téléspectateurs fin du mois les
participants pardo sont incarcérés
durant des mois c'est un programme où
les gens finissent par se battre
c'est un programme qui est gérée par un
oligarque serbe qui finance la politique
donc du coup le ca serbe n'a pas
d'incidence là dessus alors il faut
quand même rappeler qu' il y à une
guerre en 1991 entre les bosniaques et
des serbes puis les serbes contre les
croates puis serbe et croate contre les
bosniaques avant que le kosovo ne
s'enflamme à son tour pourquoi ce qui
n'apporte rien rapporte en effet ces
chaînes de télé réalité en tout cas ces
programmes ne sont pas à la hauteur des
enjeux civilisationnels qui nous
attendent
on peut même dire que les animateurs les
dirigeants ne sont finalement que des
contrôleurs en poids et mesures alors
qu'il faudrait être expert en phares et
balises leur programme moutons
n'engendre que des téléspectateurs d'or
que des téléspectateurs bouton il n'y a
pas de tir ans en esclaves vous qu'on se
le dise alors comment changer les
mentalités
alors évidemment vous avez les réseaux
sociaux qu'on connaît tous et c'est vrai
que récemment et 20 connaissez sûrement
gilles deleuze qui disait l'homme est un
petit paquet de pouvoir il est celui qui
peut et par exemple pour la télévision
pour la tison pardon pour la publicité
ils sont laurent il n'a pas fallu plus
de 48 heures pour que celle ci soit
retirée
de la circulation suite à la
mobilisation des internautes
donc on le voit effectivement la
puissance des réseaux pour changer les
mentalités en tout cas pour faire
évoluer certaines choses mais chaque
médaille a son revers
pourquoi parce que je sais plus ce que
je veux dire chaque médaille a son
revers
moi j'ai un trou parce que j'ai essayé
d'aller au delà de ce que propose
facebook faire je me suis dit comment
peut-on créer un outil qui aille au delà
des réseaux sociaux et donc je me suis
dit je vais faire un programme qui m'a
été inspiré par un film que j'ai produit
qui s'appelle l'arbre l'arbre est un
film sur le génocide des arméniens
je raconterai pas l'histoire de ce
tournage parce que je peux vous en
parler pendant des heures en tout cas
c'est un film réalisé par un rédacteur
arméniens qui s'appelle à comines cognon
et c'est un film absolument bouleversant
et pendant le tournage
on a découvert des documents un siècle
après inédit c'est ça qui est incroyable
c'est un siècle après on peut encore
retrouver des éléments
donc je me suis dit essayons de créer un
programme qui soit à mi chemin entre le
serious game et le réseau social
ce qui veut dire que l'internaute
entrera dans un écran 1
ça sera en 3d virtuelle si on le veut et
donc l'internaute se promènera dans une
ville détruite puisque un génocide c'est
non seulement la destruction des
personnes mais aussi la destruction de
la culture donc l'internaute se
déplacera dans cette rue détruites
alors on a choisi six villes
représentatives de la destruction de
l'arménie et à l'intérieur vous pourrez
vous promener à droite à gauche et voir
pourquoi pas de la musique pourquoi pas
des archives pourquoi pas de la danse en
fait tout ce qui a trait à la culture
arménienne
là dessus il y à peu près 4 millions
d'habitants en arménie mais il y à 11
millions de la diaspora 11 millions
d'arméniens dans la diaspora
mais c'est un programme qui peut
intéresser la planète entière et qui
peut intéresser bien sûr d'autres
registres que l'arménie est donc le but
de ce site c'est que la personne entrant
dans le site pourra déposer ce qu'il
veut à la fois un encouragement je ne
sais pas enfin ou une archive parce
qu'il existe encore beaucoup d'archivés
exhumé et pour faire court si vous
voulez donc sur la première rue il y
aura peut-être me l'espace et ses
espaces rempli on remontera la ville
d'un étage dans sa construction
d'origine
donc pour faire court c'est la somme des
internautes qui fera que la ville sur un
reconstruite à l'identique avant le
génocide des arméniens
c'est important parce que ça veut dire
aussi que c'est la somme des
réconciliations individuels entre
arméniens et kurdes qui favorisera la
réconcilation collective des deux
peuples
au delà évidemment des partis politiques
et des pouvoirs politiques et ça c'est
fondamental et chauve c'est une très
grande force de ce genre d'outil de
passer outre la politique voilà donc ça
c'est un c'est un premier outil tout à
fait novateur qui n'existe pas encore
sur lequel nous travaillons
le deuxième outil que je voudrais vous
développer ici parce qu'on a peu de
temps malgré tout mais qui me paraît
essentiel et qui est un peu le résultat
si je puis dire de vingtaine d'années de
production et 50 films produits c
comment peut-on amené à la connaissance
d'un plus grand nombre et surtout de la
jeunesse une forme d'intelligence et
bien on avait quelqu'un sur les
neurosciences mais je pense que
effectivement il faut s'y prendre très
tôt c'est à dire qu'il faut très tôt
proposés aux jeunes cerveaux certains
programmes et donc moi je pense qu'il
est absolument fondamentale d'inscrire
dans les programmes scolaires
alors on va dire grosso modo là je fais
un raccourci médias conso modo puisque
j'ai trois filles on va dire qu'on les
forme entre 6 ans et 16 ans je dis pas
qu après s'est passé pas perdu mais en
tout cas l'important ça se passe là donc
il faut fabriquer des programmes dès
l'âge de 6 ans d'efforts des
documentaires adaptée ça existe très
bien pour la presse aucune raison que ça
n'existe pas en audiovisuel et vous
fabriquer des preuves de 13 minutes puis
de 26 minutes puis de 52 minutes
c'est à dire qu'un enfant qui commencera
à voir des films des documentaires sur
telle ou telle thématique va dans une
année ou dans une vie sur dix ans voire
à peu près 4 500 films imaginés 4 500
films alors évidemment vous allez dire
l'écart sans rire la télévision exact
sauf que là il faut mettre d'accord
trois ministères enfin deux ministères
plus une télévision me serre la culture
ministère l'éducation nationale et une
télévision puisque la télévision pour
beaucoup d'entre vous allez désuète on
regarde du replay monde semaine ça soit
plus devant ce genre de programme or à
mon époque il y avait une émission qui
s'appelait 2 les dossiers de l'écran et
on regardait les dossiers d'écran en
famille c'est un film un débat
aujourd'hui france 5 a repris longtemps
après il était temps ce genre de mesure
ce genre de programme mais on va pas
assez loin
moi je pense qu'il faut absolument que
les les écoliers ou les étudiants et ça
c'est fait ma vie café cannes hypokhâgne
ça s'est fait à me dit mais on a fait ça
on m'a obligé à regarder sur arte un
film sur bart et le devoir du lendemain
portait justement sur le visionnage du
film de marthe parfait parfait
donc ça veut dire que dans notre cas il
faut que
les jeunes regardent ça et il ya tout à
parier que les parents s'intéresseront
aussi à regarder sur route ce que
regarder les enfants et s'est suivie
d'un débat
le débat bien évidemment c'est un débat
où il ya également le réalisateur
puisque ça
sa position est fondamentale puisque la
la la si vous donnez 10 fois lé 10 fois
le même sujet a dit réalisateur
différent vous aurez 10 films différents
donc ce qui est intéressant c'est
pourquoi précisément le réalisateur a
choisi ce point de vue dans le film
l'arbre le réacteur le réacteur arménien
sa grand mère est la seule survivante de
38 personnes assassinées par les turcs
donc son point de vue c'était quoi
c'était de remonter l'histoire de sa
grand-mère et de refaire le parcours de
sa déportation
c'est un film absolument bouleversant où
elle a même filmé les derniers les deux
derniers survivants
cent sept ans qu'ils ont avec une parole
extrêmement précises données lan point
de vue c'est absolument bouleversant est
terrible à la fois donc ça veut dire
aussi que quand vous allez donner à ces
jeunes à regarder le film vous allez
ordonné également une fiche pédagogique
vous allez leur donne également le
script c'était le déroulé du film
pourquoi parce qu'il est fondamental de
ne pas rester que dans l'image mais
aussi d'aller dans la lecture ce qui
permet aussi d'explorer des mots
nouveaux
dans le script pour les pour les jeunes
élèves
et c'est parce que malheureusement on
dit souvent que beaucoup d'élèves ne
parle qu'avec 500 mo et que beaucoup
d'entre eux ne sont pas capables
d'appréhender certains thèmes appris en
classe
donc ça me paraît fondamental donc si
vous faites ce genre de démarches furent
une dizaine d'années une fois par
semaine vous allez avoir des gens
responsables
avec une autre vision du monde quand
j'étais en arménie par exemple j'ai
appris que les échecs était une matière
obligatoire à l'école j'ai fait quoi
j'ai mis ma fille aux échecs
c'est très bon pour le cerveau les
échecs regardez poutine
bon
ce qui veut dire que c'est un bon
calculateur donc ce qui veut dire que
vous voyez avec ce genre d'outil qui
n'existe pas là encore la télévision ça
vous permet d'abord de remettre en
marche les générations entre elles 1 et
2 de favoriser à la fois là le fonds de
la fondation de la personnalité mais
aussi la socialisation et l'intégration
ok donc voila un petit peu les
brièvement puisque le temps imparti est
assez court les deux outils que je
voulais vous présenter et je dirais pour
conclure que nous notre travail de
réalisateur et de voir un final qu'une
longue vue et celui de producteur et
enfin du réservoir de l'avant avec une
loupe par dont on va au plus près les
sujets mais celui de producteur que je
suis aussi le voile et qu'ils l'ont vu
sur une aventure entrepreneuriale
voilà en tout cas c'est ces quelques
minutes accordées n'avait enfin comme la
flèche va la cible si vous voulez je
devais ciblées pour aller vers quelqu'un
vers nous voilà je vous remercie